mikola is many things a fundamentalist
the unalloid creator of the halig tree
lord of the eclipse Saint Trina of the
Cradle song and not just a demigod but a
fearsome Imperium who has been captured
but is unresponsive for now
and after watching this video I think
you'll agree that mikola is a topic that
almost has to be explored further in
some upcoming DLC for how could they not
be their character is surely too major
too foreshadowed and too intriguing to
just ignore
so let's learn everything that there is
to know
for starters mikola is the demigod child
of Queen America and King consort
Radigan who as I'm sure you're well
aware at this point are the same being
you can learn more about the timeline of
events from my other videos but
basically after Radigan left ranala the
academy told Radigan to go [__] himself
basically but Radigan took that
literally and he sired a third set of
demigod children all on his own who were
the Twins mikola and Melania these
children appear to be represented by the
butterfly items in the game and the
nascent butterfly appears to represent
mikola its description elaborates on his
state of Eternal childhood stating that
it appears as if it's just emerged from
its cocoon for its entire life indeed
the word nascent means that something is
just coming into existence and beginning
to display signs of future potential and
that nascence is eternal for Nicola and
think that this eternal nasance is
incredibly important for his character
for mikola and Melania both seem to
occupy different sides of the life and
death cycle that's not to say that
mikola represents life and Melania
represents death rather it seems like
both land somewhere in the middle of
each process Millennia is constantly
resisting her Scarlet rot and is in this
Perpetual state of dying and mikla is in
this constant state of Nations he is
newly born and showing an abundance of
life and burgeoning potential special
thanks to Quail like for making this
clear to me so mikola is nascent but
he's also abundant and I think that's
another extremely key word for him for
example there's this cut weapon called
the abundance and Decay Twin Blade which
symbolizes the Twins and suggests that
the twins were born from an Inseparable
fate and hold the Runes of both
abundance and Decay between them not to
mention the word abundance is also
literally spoken by mikola in his cut
content and thanks to a very recent
discovery by sekiro dubi we know this
cut dialogue about to voice is Nicola
speaking and here he appears to be
leading you towards a unique ending for
the game and he talks about his ability
to make life flourish stating this is
for thee mine abundance my drop of dew
quench thy thirst throughout thy frame
Blossom and burgeon time and again grow
larger stronger until the day cometh
when thou can't share in my dream Eldon
ring o Elden ring beget order most
elegant from my tender reverie and
before I go on I do want to say that
Nicola talking about his abundance is
cut content and you shouldn't really
take it as Canon but I think it does
give us a deeper look at not only the
powers that mikola might have had but
also the world that he could create he
goes on to say if thou Covetous to the
throne impress my vision upon thine
heart in the new world of thy making all
things will flourish whether graceful or
malign
and I love that final line all things
will flourish whether graceful or malign
because mikola isn't enforcing any real
Notions of good or evil here instead in
the new world of his making he simply
wants all things to flourish and I feel
like that is a very unique Viewpoint for
a character in a Soul's game not to
mention mikola is certainly one of the
few beings that is capable of creating
this new world that's because he is an
imperial he is one of the very few who
were candidates chosen by the two
fingers to succeed Queen America and
become a God to usher in a new age now
we could go into an entire debate about
why the twins are valid imperians and
why they were born Afflicted but
honestly that could almost be an entire
video of its own so for now I'll just
give the simple answer which is that
these twins were probably valid
imperians because they have singular
parentage from a God but that this
singular parentage was probably also
responsible for their afflictions as
well due to the almost ancestral
implications of such a thing why do I
feel like it was George RR Martin that
wrote this part
foreign
[Music]
anyway let's move into the Early
Childhood years of mikola's Eternal
childhood mikola's early years were
clearly quite inspired by their father
Radigan who fostered a bit of a
fundamentalist streak in his prodigal
son and mikola would go on to invent
fundamentalist incantations of his own
dubbed discus of light and triple rings
of Light which he gave as gifts to his
father these gifts reveal that Radigan
and mikola had a good relationship and
Radigan must have been proud of his son
because these two spells do represent
those two key fundamentals of the golden
order namely that there is a law of
causality which is a branching cause and
effect that goes outwards but also that
there is a law of regression that all
things yearn eternally to converge once
again and in gratitude radical
encountered with a gift of his own
showing Nicola radigan's rings of light
these incantations would go on to become
core fundamental spells as they are true
to those two concepts that form the
basis of the golden order
but there is another aspect of golden
order fundamentalism and that is the
persecution of those who live in death
Hunters of these Undead would attempt to
stamp them out with spells such as
order's blade and Litany of proper death
which deal additional damage against
those who live in death and prevent them
from resurrecting to recap those who
live in death exist because of Godwin
the golden who was one of the early sons
of America and Godfrey who was
eventually killed with a fragment of the
Rune of death and then the Rune of death
would eventually spread its undeath
throughout the lands between via death
route
and there is an entire debate that we
could have here about whether the
persecution of those who live in death
is even true to the core principles of
fundamentalism gold mask certainly
doesn't seem to think so in fact
according to the order healing spell
gold mask laments the hunters of those
who live in death deeming them to be
Fanatics who wanted nothing more than an
absolute evil to contend with and the
reason I bring up this debate at all is
because you could argue that mikola was
on the side of these fanatic Hunters as
he created multiple weapons that were
capable of effectively slaying those who
live in death for example this is golden
Epitaph and it is a sword that was made
to commemorate the death of Godwin the
golden first of the demigods to die it
is infused with the humble prayer of a
young boy and reads O Brother Lord
Brother please die a true death so this
weapon is an effective tool of killing
those who live in death permanently and
clearly the young boy who created it was
mikola we can infer this because the
sigil that appears when you use this
Blade's skill is the helic tree sigil
and once activated this ability called
last rites imbues the sword with a holy
power that prevents those who live in
Death from Reviving but beyond this
being a potential tool to slay those who
live in death is that this weapon points
towards an early kinship between mikola
and Godwin a relationship that might
have made it all the more painful when
Godwin's Soul would perish but his body
would remain spawning death route this
is interesting as it gives mikola a
legitimate emotional grievance against
those who live in death and it's almost
a bit hypocritical I think for what I
believe to be mikola's character as we
previously established that he might
have been this character who wants all
life to flourish but I guess that
principle might not extend to those who
live in death for him this sword might
not be the only representation of
mikola's relationship with Godwin that
relationship is potentially strengthened
even more when we consider this statue
found in elfel before the helic tree it
depicts a larger figure who is clearly
embracing the two imperian twins mikola
and Melania but then who is this larger
figure it could be their parent Marika
or Radigan but then it doesn't have
their signature hair braid and instead
it has this long wavy hair what's more
the statue asset is flat-chested which
appears to rule out Marika at least and
after reading a good amount of debate
online about this I think it's a fair
conclusion to say that this statue
represents Godwin who himself does seem
to have long wavy hair and this statue
being enshrined here really tells a
story it's a story of too gifted but
Afflicted siblings who were supported by
their the brother but then they were
left alone as their older brother would
become the first demigod to die and this
isn't the only statue in this location
far more prominent in the area are these
statues which depict two siblings left
alone after their brother died there was
one sibling mikola who was forced to
remain as a young child and another who
grew up in great pain eventually losing
vision and limbs to rot and Decay these
statues are everywhere in the helic tree
and they tell that sorrowful story they
are an early sign of mickler's extreme
empathy for his sister and they
foreshadow his desperate attempts to
give her relief from her terrifying
condition and so the young Nicola
abandoned fundamentalism for it could do
nothing to treat millenia's a cursed rot
this was the beginning of unalloid cold
so what is unalloid gold well an alloy
is something that's created when you
combine metals usually because you want
to create a stronger compound at the
expense of its Purity so if we were to
view America's golden order as if it
were a metal which I think is something
that the law wants you to do considering
the implications of the tarnished and
everything like that then America's
golden order would definitely be an
alloyed metal just think of all the
foreign powers that it's absorbed in the
interest of strength for example Godfrey
and his Crucible Knights were enlisted
to devastate America's enemies at the
ancient Dragons Were won over and
eventually became a part of langdale's
forces even the house of the earth tree
and the moon were married at one point
literally
after all as Muriel puts it all things
can be conjoined under the golden order
so I think America was definitely open
to fusing factions and ideologies to an
extent as long as it made her treasured
golden order alloy stronger so hopefully
now you understand what I mean when I
say that Nicholas gold is unalloid it is
pure it is untainted and it is perhaps a
singular ideology and if you subscribe
to the idea that the cut content is
still representative of mikola then I
would say that his ideology is what I
had mikola quote earlier that in his new
world all things should be allowed to
flourish whether graceful or malign and
that that is his pure ideology though of
course that is my speculation based on
Cut content as well so please keep that
in mind but Nicholas analoid gold
couldn't have just been this
metaphysical concept of pure ideology it
was a physical material as well for
example this is an unalloid gold water
lily said to have been beloved by mikola
this is a bewitching branch blessed with
an incantation of unalloid gold unalloid
gold decorated the armor and shields of
his soldiers it was inserted into their
weapons and most importantly perhaps it
was forged into a set of armor for his
sister Melania because remember the
whole reason mikola embraced unalloid
gold in the first place it seems was
because he thought that it could treat
his sisters a cursed rot while
fundamentalism could not and he was
right for millennia's scarlet rot is no
mere disease it's literally the Divine
Essence of an outer God and Melania is
its vessel that will one day Bloom into
a true goddess but amyloid gold is one
of the few materials in the game that
can Ward away such meddling of the outer
Gods another example are the mirror
Helms like the one that EG wears which
literally reflects the influence of the
outer gods and personally I think the
reason that unalloid gold inhibits the
meddling of the outer Gods is because it
is a pure metal and potentially a pure
ideology but if that's not enough reason
for you then quaalog actually has a
great video where she breaks down
potential reasons at a chemical level
but at any rate reasons aside mikola
crafted needles of unalloid gold which
could be inserted into the tortured
flesh of one afflicted by rot to
alleviate their suffering and forestall
the effects of the rot and true to the
needles descriptions the outer God of
rot isn't the only one affected by this
our character actually uses the final
version of this unalloid gold needle to
subdue the outer God of frenzy which is
something you might want if you decided
to be a terrible person
burned down the world anyway when we
first Find nikola's needle it's been
broken snapped in half and picked up by
a commander at the very center of the
Scarlet swamp but once this needle has
been prepared we can give the Golden
Needle to Millicent proving that it does
indeed work to forestall the rotting
sickness to remove pain and Nightmares
From The Afflicted it is after all
lovingly crafted by mikola himself well
well this is a marble indeed the work of
a true Artisan a meticulous bold
Craftsman who grasps the essence of life
in crafting these needles and pursuing
unalloid gold mikola is attempting to
save his sister from her Affliction it
seems like this objectively good deed
which is a rare sight in Elden ring
especially for a demigod whose strengths
have been known to tip them towards
Madness and that is what makes mikola
such a pure and likable character in
Olden ring so it's is no wonder really
that Melania venerated her brother she
is a character of undefeated prowess and
she's an Imperium no less and yet she
dedicated her blade to mikola and mikola
alone for she believes that he possesses
the wisdom the Allure of a God and that
he is the most fearsome imperian of all
the story of their bond and duty to one
another is legendary and that's
something that becomes quite clear when
we explore mikolas halik tree and see
these statues depicting their embrace
all around and if you were one of the
many defiled outcasts in Eldon ring you
two might have felt inspired by this
story and you might have felt inclined
to earn Nicholas favor and make the long
pilgrimage towards your salvation
towards the distant Divine halictory and
its brace that was nikola's domain
foreign
so first what even is the helic tree
well it's pretty obvious that it's a
sort of ERD tree for one oak tree
avatars have clearly emerged from it
which they only do in order to protect
the old trees of an offspring and then
there's the helic tree Knight armor
which confirms that the helic tree
ultimately failed to grow into an earth
tree and one thing I've been wondering
is when exactly was the helic tree
planted then if we knew when then we
might be able to guess at its purpose
was it planted before or after the
shattering of the Elden ring because
when the Elden ring was shattered golden
seeds flew from the earth tree
scattering across the various lands as
if life itself knew that its end had
come these seeds create these little
illusory trees and likely spawned the
minor herb trees as well so I think it's
a fair assumption that mikola might have
planted the helic tree from an earth
tree seed and if that was was indeed the
case then it should have happened after
the shattering for before that the Earth
tree was considered perfect and eternal
and it wasn't even believed that old
tree seeds could exist but on the flip
side the golden Epitaph sword that we
mentioned earlier likely existed before
the shattering as it was created to
commemorate Godwin's death and this
sword displays the helic tree sigil when
its weapon art is activated so one could
infer that the helic tree must have
existed at this point too right so I
guess it's always possible that Nicola
somehow procured an odd tree seed before
the shattering or simply grew it from
his own being as he is a Scion of the
golden bow after all but whatever the
case mikola clearly decided that growing
such a tree was important and he even
went so far as to water it with his own
blood this confirms that the Earth tree
is indeed a blood-sucking parasite just
kidding sort of I mean have to admit it
is pretty disturbing that an earth tree
could flourish in such a manner but this
does lead us to the final question which
is why was the helic tree planted what
was the point of it and at the end of
the day the main reason is always going
to be because it's like the Earth tree
it's natural to compare them and the
item descriptions seem to want you to
compare them as well the oak tree is
this enormous icon of power and faith in
the lands between so evoking that and
inspiring worship is clearly a valuable
thing but the Earth tree was only really
an icon of faith in its later years
before that it was a symbol of abundance
with light as warm as the gentle Sun
that could gradually heal all those who
bathed in its rays but perhaps most
importantly during this time of
abundance it would drip sacred Dew sap
or tears that could bestow blessings
form Crystal tears and even be embedded
into talismans these were treasured
things
naturally this was an extremely valuable
symbol for mikola to evoke since he is
himself associated with Jew and
abundance in the cut content and his
helic tree did drip with Dew the
greenish Amber of the helic tree can
even be seen in Cut content items it
even looks as if it's mingled with a bit
of mikola's own blood and that signature
green Hue of helic tree Amber is also
seen in the helic tree knight sword
which is not a cut weapon and this was
modeled after the carrion Knight's own
swords except it was embedded with Amber
from the halig tree instead of Glenstone
okay so the helic tree is a great symbol
of faith and power and abundance and
mikola is related to abundance in the
cat content but what else does the halik
tree add in terms of value well the
helic tree itself is something of a
vessel fit for a god mikola plants
himself inside it later on Melania
returns home to it and speaking of it
being a home many other creatures have
made their home within the tree and
within the brace that supports it as
well and I guess you could also argue
that the helic tree might be a sort of a
tool to be used after all Marika puts
the urge tree to use in such a way using
its roots to absorb people after their
death and perhaps even its branches to
rebirth life and then the oak tree is
later used as a prison with thorns that
are almost entirely impenetrable but I
don't think Michaela planned to use the
helic tree in such a way perhaps the
biggest difference between the Haley
tree and the old tree is that the helic
tree was built in a largely inhospitable
region it is extremely difficult to
reach and unlike the Earth tree it might
not really be designed for the benefit
of the vast majority of the world as it
stands the helic tree strikes me as
being more like the Painted World from
Dark Souls it's a place for the outcasts
the heretical and the malign not to
mention the Lo and the make who are
specifically named in the description of
the Sacred Crown Helm while many of the
Scarlet Rod Afflicted seem to be here
because of the eventual decay of the
helic tree I think that there are a
number of refugees here that would have
been here before that namely the Miss
begotten the crystalian these astray
Mages of Raya lucaria and of course
Loretta who deemed this place to be a
great Haven for the despised albanorics
the second generation albanorics even
carry a weapon called the ivory sickle
which reads these weapons are evidence
of their dedication to the helic tree
despite never having entered its
presence and we really don't find a
single albenoric within the helic tree
I'll admit I do find this a bit strange
you do find quite a few albanorex so
close to the helic tree it's a bit
strange to me they don't go just that
little bit further the reason given for
the first generation of albinorex not
being at the halib tree is given by
Albus who says that their faded legs are
the reason for that but yeah we find
them defending mikola and his halig tree
all the same at the ordina liturgical
town which takes us to the helic tree
via a puzzle within an Eva jail the word
liturgical means relating to public
worship and this town is fittingly
filled with many statues of mikola
sitting alone cradling what might have
become the helic tree back when it was
still just a sapling I also find it
interesting that the helic tree is never
called out as competing with the urge
tree or never called out for housing all
these undesirables perhaps The House of
the old tree was happy to see ungraceful
folk leave their lands perhaps the helic
tree was extremely well hidden from
everyone and they didn't know or perhaps
mikola could just get away with it
because he was beloved by all for
example the bewitching branch is is an
item that you can create from Nicholas
lilies and it is blessed with an
incantation of unalloid gold and reads
the imperian mikola is loved by many
people indeed he has learned very well
how to compel such affection and that
second part that says he has learned how
to compel affection to me that's saying
that mikola is very good at knowing how
to inspire others affection to his own
advantage and nowhere is this more clear
I think than at Castle
this is the Haley tree secret Medallion
it's furnished with that signature green
Amber and it features the helic tree in
the background for it allows you to
access a secret lower level of the grand
lift of rolled and progress through the
consecrated snow fields to this sacred
Place having both halves of this secret
Medallion is therefore extremely
desirable for The Medallion has another
name it's called mikola's favor
Michaela's favorite can be yours
Slaughter
flutter
to all hearing slaughtered butterless
it was for not
but all you need to is snatch it from
the big pot Gideon is the all-hearing
man in this dialogue and he slaughtered
an entire Village just for one half of
this Medallion but he did not find it in
albus's possession but you can and the
other half is it Castle Soul right
before a nameless Phantom who says this
Lord mikola forgive me the sun has not
been swallowed our prayers were lacking
your comrade remains soulless I will
never set my eyes upon it now Your
Divine helic tree
so this Phantom seemingly has or I guess
had one half of The Medallion and yet he
laments that he will now never set eyes
upon the halik tree to me this suggests
that mikola might have been withholding
the second half of The Medallion from
him or that this Phantom believed that
he could solicit the second half of The
Medallion from mikola and make it to the
helic tree if he achieved his goal here
at Castle soul and basically earned
mikola's favor
what exactly was supposed to happen here
at Castle Soul what does it mean when
the Phantom says the sun has not been
swallowed our prayers were lacking your
comrade remains soulless it means I
think that the residents of Castle soul
and mikola were attempting to restore
the dead soul of Godwin the golden and
just to refresh your memory when a
fragment of the Rune of death was used
to kill Godwin it was also being used at
the exact same time to kill Rani and
since they perished at the same time
Rani lost her body and Nicolas demigod
brother Godwin perished in Seoul alone
and despite this death seeming so final
mikola clearly believes that some sort
of ritual performed here could restore
the soul of his comrade for example
here's some more dialogue from a
different Phantom that reads oh great
Sun frigid son of Soul surrender
yourself to the eclipse Grant life to
the soulless bones
the question is how how does that work
how does an eclipse Restore Life to
Godwin now you can just take mikola at
face value and trust that he knows what
he's doing or we can try to learn as
much as we can about the eclipse and see
if we can reason out the mechanism
behind this process so at Castle Soul we
find the Eclipse chotel which reads
storied sword and Treasure of Castle
soul that depicts an eclipsed Sun
drained of color in Seoul the sight of
an eclipse inspires a dreadful ore
preventing a non-looker from averting
his gaze the most important part of this
description though is the part that says
it's the storied sword of Castle Soul as
this proves that the veneration of the
eclipse here goes back a long way but
what does an eclipse represent so
according to the eclipse Crest Shields
the eclipsed sun drained of color is the
protective star of soulless demigods
honestly I think calling it a protective
star is kind of the closest we come to
understanding the mechanism here
reason that a protective star might be a
sort of outer God that lends them power
though that is just speculation the
description goes on to say that the sun
in Eclipse is said to be the symbol of
the wandering Mausoleum where the
soulless demigods Slumber so note that
it says demigods plural here now this
could be because the wandering
mausoleums come to house many demigods
from a gameplay point of view because
you can take their remembrances here but
it could be a word that is slightly Lost
in Translation as the Japanese version
of the word demigods does not specify
whether it's a plural or whether it's a
singular word so my take on this is that
I think the wandering mausoleums became
necessary when Godwin died I think that
the mausoleum was intended to be a
resting place for him initially but then
also for any future demigods as all of a
sudden all of their true deaths had
become possible as well with the theft
of a fragment of the Rune of death
the mausoleum Knights themselves are
these headless soldiers who behead
themselves willingly following their
Master into death as such they become
these headless Spirits tied to the land
so that they might better defend the
walking mausoleums they also carry
Eclipse crested Shields and the eclipse
is said to Aid the mausoleum Knights by
keeping destined death at Bay it is
their symbol and by keeping destined
death at Bay maybe it's helping to keep
their souls tied to the land we could
speculate for a long time on how the
eclipse has this power and I've done my
best maybe other people have a better
take on it and maybe you guys do in the
comments but in the end it's simpler
just to trust that Michelin knew what he
was doing with the eclipse at Castle
Soul where he wanted to block out the
Sun and restore Godwin's Soul all that
said we can't trust him too much I guess
because it's important to remember that
this ritual failed according to this
Phantom the sun was not swallowed I
guess the protective star of The
Soulless demigods did not listen to
their prayers and it did not appear but
it is really fascinating to learn that
such a thing might even be possible that
Godwin whose Soul seems to be as dead as
rani's body might actually not be so if
his soul is somewhere then where has it
fled to a part of me wonders if his soul
is lost then maybe it's lost within a
dream one Theory I did come up with
regarding the mechanism by which
Godwin's soul is brought back by the
eclipse is that his soul might be
brought back by bringing about a sort of
artificial dusk with the eclipse that's
because those who live in death are
called The Dusk born after all so there
is an association between night and
death to be sure and there's also an
association between death and sleep for
example when you pursue fear's questline
you use her as a medium to enter
Godwin's deathbed dream which is an
entire Dreamscape where the dragon
Fortis ax is futile fighting against the
Death In His companion and then there's
Roger who speaks this line of dialogue
as he is on the precipice of succumbing
to death root
maybe I should tell you
lately I feel I'm on the precipice of
falling into a deep
fathomless Slumber he does say he's
about to fall into sleep so in
conclusion a realm of death does seem
accessible through dream and I think
this is the perfect time to mention that
mikola has an alter ego some say she is
a comely young girl others are sure he
is a boy this is where we have to talk
about the enigmatic figure named Saint
Trina
perhaps the biggest in-game clue about
Saint Trina's true identity is Trina's
Lily which Bears this undeniable
resemblance to Nicola's Lily of unalloid
gold its description reveals that it is
a symbol of faith in Saint Trina dulls
the senses preventing agitation
naturally it can be used to craft a
bunch of sleep afflicting items like
Saint Trina's Arrow which states that
the sweet Oblivion of sleep can become
quite the habit and it tells of the
priests of Saint Trina who use these
arrows to spread their teachings though
the Japanese description seems to
specify that these were more of a tool
used for their rituals so it's largely
left to your imagination as to what
rituals these priests might have been
performing though I will mention that it
seems Saint Trina might actually be able
to be found somewhere within sleep this
is suggested by feathers cookbook which
reads A record of crafting techniques
left by a man who was utterly captivated
by Saint Trina he continued the search
for her in his Slumber we get a side
profile of her in the hilt of Saint
Trina's sword which hints at that
flowing a stray hair that she has and
then we get a much better front-on view
of this feminine adult form upon Saint
Trina's torch the carvings depict Saint
Trina but in adult form somewhat
unnervingly The Carving is indeed
unnerving and it's certainly strange
considering mikola is supposed to be
eternally a child it raises the question
what has to happen for mikola to grow up
into this and why is this bizarre
creature the adult form that he takes
another question worth asking I think is
whether mikola even has total control of
Saint Trina what if he's in a similar
situation to Marika Radigan where their
alter ego is an opposite of sorts and
able to act almost as if they have their
own Free Will so all of this is
definitely a little bit of a disturbing
view of what saint Trina could be but I
guess we do have cut content that does
somewhat reassure me that the alter ego
is still a benevolent person this cut
content was first showcased by sekito
dubi and this cut content is truly
ancient it exists in one of the oldest
versions of the game that we know about
so a lot has probably changed since then
but regardless here we can learn about
Saint Trina's crystal ball which once
read a crystal ball full of mist symbol
of Saint Trina of the Cradle song copies
dream mist from a sleeping being dream
Mist was once used as an ingredient in
rare and potent physics May the quietude
of Slumber come to all and Sundry even
to those whose red eyes burn with the
Flames of frenzy so this reveals that
this cut version of Saint Trina even
once had sympathy for those afflicted by
the flame of frenzy they even went so
far as to teach the merchants their
songs
Our Song derives from an old lullaby
song for us now we're gone deep inside
our tomb that's
no longer
it's a Melody allowed us to sleep
despite because it Flame
the description of mikola's songs as a
lullaby is referenced by the modern day
sleep pot description which reads like a
lullaby or a quagmire its light purple
haze irresistibly draws its victims down
into sleep sweet dreams this is the
closest thing we have to dream Mist as
well which was an item that you could
again once collect from sleeping enemies
and after you did this you were supposed
to sell the stream Mist to the merchants
who used it to quell their flame of
frenzy but as the merchants once said
whoever it was that sings now sings no
longer and this is a detail that has
remained intact even in the final
version of Elden ring with Saint Trina's
sword stating that Saint Trina's
appearance was as sudden as their
disappearance something clearly happened
to mikola that prevented them from
continuing their work as Saint Trina and
that is what we will discuss next
at some point Michala embedded himself
into the helic tree why he did this is
never explicitly stated but I think we
can make a good attempt at puzzling it
out so mikola famously watered the halig
tree with his own blood since it was a
sapling so I guess you could argue that
he embedded himself in it to Simply feed
the tree more which I guess is possible
because the tree does eventually wither
without mikola inside it and Gideon
seems to tie his removal with the death
of the helic tree or it's turning into a
husk but I don't think that can be the
only reason why he embedded himself for
instance look closely at the halig tree
roots and you'll see the form of a
tree-like woman and where her womb
should be there's a Gap a gap that once
contained mikola's cocoon cradled by the
halig tree now either mikola was
attempting to fuse into and become this
woman like figure who might even be the
adult forms shown on Saint Trina's torch
or there was a rebirth occurring here
this is a cocoon within a womb after all
so rebirth could have been the intent
here but regardless it seems things
ended prematurely for mikola would
eventually be ripped out of the womb and
the helic tree would split and Decay and
so when we arrive at the helic tree and
the town of elfel that is built into the
brace that supports it the music here
hits extremely hard this place is just
so sorrowful for the helic tree and
Nicholas lilies and even centrino's
lilies are all wilting and all who live
here are just hoping and praying for
their lord to return I love the little
detail of the guards looking outwards
and sitting dejectedly to make matters
worse for them it was here that they
realized that the sacred light inside
them would explode upon their imminent
deaths and yet in spite of this their
Spirit ashes show their faith and state
May the Flesh of our deaths guide
mikola's return and Millennia is here
too holding to the husk of mikola
dreaming and waiting for mikola to
return and believing full well that he
will
corpse after corpse left in my wake
as I waited
is returned
melania's set reveals that she believes
her brother will keep his promise so
what was that promise I wonder was it
merely to return or was it something
more how much does Melania know why did
she fight Redan we'll have to talk about
all of that in another video so there is
still Faith there's even this one
Phantom in the consecrated snow fields
who has somehow puzzled out who took
mikola and even where they are he is
pointed towards the portal that takes
you to mowgun Palace and Moog The Omen
so indeed it was the demigod Moog who
somehow broke into the halig tree and
absconded with mikola's infant form and
it's with him that the story ends or
maybe it's where this story truly begins
so if you're not familiar Moog is the
omen son of Godfrey and America and
being an omen of royalty he was born
into a wretched mire of Filth in the
Subterranean shunning grounds below
Langdale Capital but unlike his brother
morgot who reviled his accursed blood
Moog reveled in it and it was assumingly
because of this accursed blood that he
chanced a meeting with an outer God
called the mother of Truth and as Moog
stood before her deep underground his
accursed blood erupted with fire and he
was truly besotted with the defilement
that he was born into Moog is just one
of many characters who discovers a new
identity in the ways that they have been
discarded by the world and how could he
not for his defilement was validated by
nothing less than an outer God and as
always we know very little about this
outer God we know she is called the
mother of truth and the formless mother
we know that she desires wounds and
bestows power upon accursed blood her
followers can thrust their arms into her
body to scatter blood flame and
followers of Moog can share in The Lord
of blood's power and send bloodflies
before them there's even been some
speculation in my recent shorts and my
tick tocks as well that the formless
mother is also an outer God called The
Blood star
but the one thing that all outer Gods
seem to have in common is that they all
require vessels to move through so in
this case the formless mother's vessel
was Moog for example the sacred spear
that he wields is a weapon but it's also
an instrument of communion and Moog May
well be doing her bidding with his
actions these actions included him
starting a new Dynasty called mogwan
deep below the Earth in the grounds of
these ancient dynastic remains this is a
secret place difficult to reach and it
was here that Moog brought the infant
mikola torn as he was from his cocoon I
mean that's how we see him in his
opening cut scene but in game Nicola
seems to be back with a new cocoon here
you can even see it sat upon this giant
pelvic bone which seems to be a
reference to the womb of the helic tree
woman that he was literally ripped from
and it's from the remembrance of the
blood Lord that we can learn of moog's
intent here he wished to raise mikola to
full godhood and become his consort
taking the role of Monarch to this end
Moog has begun soliciting blood
offerings to mikola and that certainly
explains the state of so many who reside
here according to the Lord of blood's
exaltation Talisman he proclaimed render
up your offerings of blood to your lord
drench my consorts chamber slake his
cocoon's thirst his Awakening shall
Herald the dawn of our Dynasty and then
to return to moog's remembrance it
stated that so far this has all been in
vain for no matter how much of his
bloody bed chamber Moog tried to share
he received no response from The Young
Imperium so maybe nothing will happen or
maybe according to the pure blood
Knights medal it is not yet time for
Moog yet Slumbers beside the Divinity be
patient the new new Dynasty is not what
do you think I mean it's kind of hard to
know even Gideon has no clue but
something does seem to be happening to
mikola in there he has clearly grown for
one since being taken so maybe his adult
form is manifesting and personally this
is really speculation but this reminds
me a lot of Berserk which we know
Miyazaki is always inspired by spoiler
warning really you should watch that
show but there's this moment at the very
end of the first chapter where Griffith
betrays his companions in this
sacrificial ceremony of Carnage and
bloodshed in order to be inaugurated and
reborn as a God within an egg of sorts
this really reminds me of that it also
reminds me of scene with Griffith where
he allows himself to be abused basically
in order to get what he wants so I
wonder what if this was also what mikola
wanted we know that he is extremely
proficient at compelling others to love
him and Moog is clearly enraptured we
know that mikola is an imperial Prodigy
and we know that his sister who knows
him best has total faith that he will
return so you'd think he's still in
control of the situation somehow but
that could be a part of the tragedy and
mikola this benevolent being might not
have predicted this at all and is now
being completely taken advantage of or
maybe he did intend to be taken but he's
going to get more than he bargained for
with the mother of Truth or maybe
Nicholas fate really is long gone
there's one other thing I want to
mention there is this place called
mickler's Hideaway in the Altus plateau
and here we can loot Amber Starlight
which sullivas mentions is the very fate
of a demigod clearly since it's here
you'd think it's Nicholas fate right and
then you also have to consider that the
cut content that we are basing so much
of this video on is very much removed
from the game because it might not fit
the developer's intent that's always
possible so I really do hope you all
bear that in mind as I would really hate
to promote ideas that are against the
developer's vision for this character
but I really do think that it's a
possibility that we're going to one day
enter the dream of this slumbering
demigod after all there was once a cut
character called Rico who was supposed
to say the following standing before
nikola's cocoon at mowgun Palace he says
finally I have found it Saint Trina's no
Lord Nicholas cadaver such that I may
Aid You O Lord so please I hope you
welcome your humble servant Rico into
your dream the world of your heart
indeed I beg you grant my wish that when
you transcend from imperian to God allow
me a place by your side
plus if we do get DLC it's going to need
a new great Rune to acquire right that's
a huge gameplay mechanic in these games
and it'd be weird if DLC came and you
couldn't get more great runes
apart from Michael's great room the only
one we don't know about also is Ronnie's
great Rune which was allegedly cast
aside so there's always that to consider
but hopefully we get some DLC to answer
these questions or more likely we'll get
DLC that will give us more questions
than we started with that's always how
it seems to go but I really hope they
throw us some good curveballs with this
one as they always do but regardless
it's always a ton of fun to speculate
with you all so if you're still
listening to this extremely long video
thank you for giving me your time today
thank you to quelagh for reviewing the
script for me thank you misspap for the
incredible visuals as always and I also
want to give a sincere and really
reverential shout out to Eugenia Elisa
who created the speculative visuals of
Saint Trina please follow her work in
the description she's one of the most
talented artists that I've ever known
and yeah thank you as always of course
for watching my videos and I'll see you
next time